Adele introduce yourself okay hi I'm
Adele Myers I am currently getting a PhD
in physics at UC Santa Barbara but my
current research is in analyzing
biological shapes with Nina Milan in the
bioshape lab
um
when we say biological shapes we mean
things like the shapes of like the
outline of a cell specifically the
membrane of a cell or we could mean
something like a 3D shape of the
surface of a brain or the 3D shape of a
heart or something like that but my most
recent paper which is titled
regression-based metric learning on
shape spaces of cell curves which I will
be presenting next Friday virtually at
the workshop that the nurix workshop
mean learning meaningful representations
of life this paper specifically
considers a cell membrane as a bylock as
a biological shape so cells
evolve over time and as they evolve they
often change in shape so the mem the
shape of the cell membrane will change
over time
and we wanted to look more closely at
this problem specifically at cell
migration because cell migration is
essential to a lot of
things in life hence finding meaningful
representations of life it was perfect
for our topic
so we wanted to find the best way to
quantify
changes in cell shape over time
a lot of biologists quantify cell shape
with things like circularity or
convexity or perimeter of the cell or
area of the cell but we wanted to find a
way that to analyze these cell shapes
that was a bit more mathematically
robust specifically to try to quantify
the difference in cell shape in a way
that was mathematically robust so step
one
if you consider one cell shape we take
samples along the surface of the cell or
the the outline of the cell
step two
once we've taken a bunch of samples
around the outline of the cell we
project this discrete curve onto an
object space
and step three do that for the entire
cell trajectory so if we are considering
a cell as it changes over time you'll
have one cell at one time Point another
cell at another time Point another sell
at another time point so we
project all of those cells onto the
shape space where they then form a
trajectory in the shape space
next we quotient by rotation scaling
translation and now all of these cells
lie on the manifold of discrete curves
now now we're on a Romanian manifold and
to Define any sort of distance on this
riemannian manifold we have to define a
riemannian metric
specifically we Define the elastic
metric or a family of elastic metrics
and this is important because we are
about to do a regression model on the
manifold of discrete curves so if we
want to do regression then we have to
Define distance
um the elastic metric is very well
suited to analyze distances between two
curves cell Curves in this case because
it depends on two parameters a bending
parameter and a stretching parameter
so Romanian metrics again Define
distances on riemannian manifolds and a
and b the bending parameter and the
stretching parameter Define these
distances between cells based off of how
bent or stretched they are compared to
each other when I say stretched I mean
if this is a circle
then this is a stretched Circle
if this is a stretched Circle
then this is a bent stretched Circle
so that's bending and stretching and
that is the bending parameter and the
stretching parameter that we're
considering in the family of elastic
metrics that our paper considers
so the so now we've defined the elastic
metric we've defined the manifold of
discrete curves that we're considering
and next we are going to go back to the
concept of regression
our goal our initial goal was to try to
best fit a trajectory of cell curves
with regression the simplest form of
regression is geodesic regression which
is similar to linear regression if it
were a linear space so in a linear space
which is like x y z however many
dimensions
that would be linear regression but on a
manifold we consider geodesic regression
that's the simplest form of regression
but
okay now we want to do geodesic
regression on the trajectory of shapes
but if we want to do geodesic regression
then we have to define a metric but if
we Define a metric then we have to
choose a and b because well if we're
doing an elastic metric
however that leads us to the question
what A and B do we choose and that is
what our paper
riemannian-based elastic metric learning
does our paper learns the A and B that
will optimize geodesic regression on the
manifold of discrete curves for a
specific trajectory
um
so Step One is first we came up with a
an explicit gradient of the coefficient
of determination
the coefficient of determination is that
r squared term that you see in
statistics classes
and it essentially describes how well
your data
is Being Fit
by the regression model
um
so that that's kind of our our loss
function we did we
Define we describe how well a geodesic
regression fit is describing the
trajectory based off of its coefficient
of determination
so we first find the coefficient of
determination
with respect to A and B the elastic
metric parameters bending and stretching
parameters then we find the gradient of
r squared with respect to A and B
and then we perform a gradient Ascent
algorithm
to try to find the the A and B that will
off that will maximize r squared and
thus optimize
regression on the manifold of three
curves
um so
step one again we're going in Steps step
one is to create a synthetic data
trajectory we
um we create this synthetic trajectory
between two real cancer cells so that
the synthetic trajectory will be
realistic cells
um
next we decide what our true metric
parameters are going to be so that we
know with certainty that this synthetic
trajectory is going to follow a geodesic
in
in whatever metric you're choosing
um
so now you have a synthetic trajectory
that you know follows a geodesic with
some given a and b
this geodesic this geodesic synthetic
geodesic trajectory will not necessarily
be a geodesic if you choose different A
and B parameters so then our
code learns the A and B parameters
without knowing the true a and true B if
you give it an input a b then it will
learn the A and B parameters that where
the trajectory follows a geodesic and um
we compared our work against the SRV
metric which is a special case of this
elastic metric where I think a yeah a is
equal to one and B is equal to 0.5 and
um
our learned parameters
often well they they most of the time
outperforms the SRV metric as long as a
and b weren't close to the SRV metric so
we were pretty excited about that and
then the next step is to test on real
data to try to
quantify on real cells how much a cell
bends and stretches over time which then
biologists can use to try to
differentiate between different types of
cells or
different yeah different cell
trajectories amazing so I've got a
question I'm really interested in I'm a
machine learning guy so I'm interested
in building representations of the world
okay and in this particular
representation we're talking about
um you know shape space and having this
ability to discretely represent surfaces
and so on right so
this must surely introduce some level of
approximation error depending on your
level of discretization or your level of
resolution and definitely I was just
wondering
um how much approximation error is it
and how did you kind of like presumably
you tweaked the parameters to find it a
an appropriate trade-off there yeah
so
let me know if this this answer is
answering your question
we did test our
code on
on trajectories with varying levels of
noise and varying levels of sampling
points and varying levels of the number
of cells in your trajectory
and it our code definitely worked better
with some with you know low noise
surprisingly it actually worked well
with around 30 to 50 sampling points
when we had much more sampling many more
sampling points than that it didn't work
as well and of course it also worked
well when there were lots of cells in
the cell trajectory
is that what you were asking yeah okay
yeah that's really good anything else
you know what
uh how are you finding new age nurps is
so fun I don't have that strong of well
I've actually never formally learned
machine learning before so it's really
fun to just go up to all of the poster
presenters and
ask the experts about their work
yeah everyone's really nice and smart
well
um it's so interesting because I was
speaking with Adele before we started
filming and um you're basically talking
another language to me and and that's a
great representation of we have all of
these intersectional fields and we have
very specialized expertise in in our
respective fields and it's so
interesting when we all come together
and share the same space yeah I guess
that's the whole point of of coming here
I'm really really happy that I was able
to come amazing well thank you so much
that was amazing interview I really
appreciate it thank you so much cool